no I'm grace Helbig no no you know it's
different now
there has been a huge trend recently on
YouTube where people follow other people
to makeup tutorial and I don't know why
that's a trend because that's literally
what we've all been doing for the last
seven eight nine ten years I've done a
few drag a makeup tutorial follow things
you know what while this trend is hot
let me jump back into something I've
already done and try to get views I
don't know I've done this before because
I genuinely do not know how to do makeup
and I think that the people that do know
how to do makeup are so cool I'm gonna
try again even though I felt many many
times somehow I still have the self
esteem that that could maybe do it this
time around I went on Twitter and I
asked you guys who is a makeup tutorial
I should follow and so many of you
recommended slamming for which I didn't
know about until you guys just
recommended it to me that's the beauty
of YouTube and social media so girl
named Mikey your description says I'm a
self-taught LA based professional beauty
and special effects makeup artist things
were about to get pretty ugly
she likes puns I like her already so as
soon as I started going through her
videos I realized that a lot of them are
super special effects heavy which is
really cool because they look awesome
but as of now I do not have the means to
try and do this maybe in the future
though but I found one when I just
scrolled through that really struck a
chord with me and Knox inspired mess
makeup tutorial I've never seen Mad Max
but I like to think that I'm an inspired
mess so this one I think might be the
one I say yes to the mess Oh first I
should take off I have makeup on already
wearing my makeup wipes I literally
covered this table and stuff that I
thought I could use without having to
get up and oh dang it
I'm gonna take my eye and eyebrow makeup
off Wow I had these sensitive makeup
wipes making my eyes hair an eye
infection who me
what what a look who is she no one knows
but she's definitely got allergies oh
she's like your dogs well I have no
comment this makeup look is let's do it
okay so I lied I had a starting point of
inspiration whoa whoa whoa she's diving
right
only a six minute tutorial so Holly she
have face makeup on her ready do I find
out later that she's putting face sheet
on also I haven't seen Mad Max but I've
gone nuts at a t.j.maxx so some might
call me a Mad Max any step 5 she might
have perfect skin
I don't know this beautiful woman I'm
going to just for the sake of it cover
my bases by covering my base oh I need
that other foundation I don't know what
she's using what are you using oh so I
guess she has our full face makeup done
and then she put on these in tents Cara
deviled eggs eyebrows so let's do that
whoa Kieffer I watched a couple of her
makeup tutorials and this one seemed the
most balanced in terms of like slightly
out of the box and all what no one here
just saw a ghost what are you talking
about this one seemed like the most like
thing that I could actually try to do
and try to do well without it being
super special effects heavy off to a
great start let's just do eyebrows I
don't know what products you use but I'm
using this NYX eyebrow cake powder I
want you guys to know that I'm going to
try to do the way she does it
as a little grass step these look like
that eyebrows on those fake glasses that
you get at Party City everyone looks so
nice kind of damn it wow wow I look
healthy and not like I have jaundice at
all so eyebrow base goes on she's using
a white a much waiter won the night so
she's putting white eye shadow on the
top and bottom I have this white shadow
in this contour palette so let's use
that whoa she hates bugs the way I hate
bugs I look like a human that might want
to be a mime but it's really like here
you see me lining up the rainbow on my
eyelids using sugar pills Pro palette
and a pigment from McLaren okay so she's
doing some turquoises on the outside
edge what did you do you went so fast I
leave because I wanted the color to show
through differently on each eye once I
threw a bunch of black eyeshadow all
over my face I what this now it's at
Oriel this is just your doing stuff so
she puts the colors differently on each
eyelid I really want this to be good oh
there we go
it's just not as pigmented as the color
she's using what the what all right okay
you're going nuts I'm just gonna start
combining colors to look sort of like
what you're doing
[Music]
whoa whoa there she is
I think post-apocalyptic I think
industrial but I think industrial I
think the rest run off and aren't even
textured so if anyone is ever recreating
this look ever me just she's perfect
[Music]
okay she may be different mess on the
other side using reds oranges and
yellows which I definitely don't have
[Music]
she's so relatable yes the questions
were all thinking she's basically just
donate or bottle on destruction I don't
mind so useful considering probably no
long actually doing this face little did
she know I should also quickly mention
the bulk of the kool-aid outfit when
that game with an excessive amount of
product on my brush and let that fall
under my face Davidson texture I wanted
to pull the black in between the colors
to break them up in and get the overall
of that crunchy dirty you might have
stuck my face find someone's
post-apocalyptic
dirt biking exhaust kind of look okay
give me some black liner that's fish
didn't do that so like whoa but there's
no instruction should now she's putting
black eyeshadow
how did she get from that to that
smudges it everywhere my kind of makeup
tutorial looks like I just cried into a
funfetti cake on that I don't think it
inspired mass weight so she puts it
above her eyebrows to an honor eyebrows
where are the instruction I know you
think no one's gonna do it I gotta look
like I'm sitting up a smoke alarm but I
don't know how to do it cuz she didn't
explain it but you're very nice blended
in I don't know I want to look like an
idiot well cool didn't I guess not that
dogs cool mascara all right give me a
second to get to the eyelashes we can do
this we're doing it for the sake of our
know it oh well when they don't give up
and I assume the worst
I'm good at things did I just get okay
putting on fake eyelashes solution this
is also are in the same time that's look
like from accidental rebo run off to
some strange version about my queen
Joker I said Anna noise oh she just did
so much all at once basically like a
blackish then I got these lip color and
her police rash thing that looks normal
and cool I used Kat Von D's awakens sad
weird little streaks to parts on my lips
because it was looking too flat white
concealer whoa quick to your you got a
whole thing eek Oh hold on
[Music]
well thank you guys so much for watching
this I try to follow a glam and gore
makeup tutorial let me know think in the
comments down below I know you will
anyway obviously go check out slammin
core because she is the sweetest cutest
artistically talented fun person and I
hope I did her justice don't forget to
click subscribe to this YouTube channel
I make videos Tuesday and Thursday as of
this moment in time but who knows what's
gonna happens with that bill
notifications they get notified when
they get uploaded other than that I
don't know oh ok serving Bert and Ernie
realness right now